So many people have asked blockchain
technology,
provide answers to challenges that
typically have suffered from lack of
technology that they've suffered from
poor technology applications.
One of those being the way the voting
works in the United States.
Uh,
there's a,
I think of this in three different
distinct phases,
right?
There's the phase before voting were
keeping track of who is registered to
vote,
uh,
and where they're allowed to vote has
seems it's been harder than it should
have been,
right?
We have a lot of examples of people
showing up at polling places and being
denied the right to vote.
Uh,
it,
it seems like paperwork goes missing and
people get removed from voting roles,
that sort of thing.
A public ledger that tracks who is
registered to vote were and allowed
people to look at that from their home
machine and then confirm that when they
showed up at the pole,
would do a lot to reestablish trust in
the process of registering to vote and
validating that everybody who is
entitled to vote,
uh,
is able to do that right.
Providing an independent verification of
that.
Um,
the,
uh,
there's a second phase I'll get to in a
bit,
but there's a third phase which is after
the vote,
when you're taking the totals that come
from a polling place that come from,
you know,
vote by mail,
for example,
in Oregon,
we have to kind of trust that the system
works,
right?
We have to hope that everything is
counted correctly at the local level and
then it's totaled up correctly,
the state level and then reported
nationally,
etc. And we're fortunately the point
where that,
that,
the basis of that trust hasn't been
violated yet,
but in many countries it is in many
countries,
there's not a lot of confidence that the
total from a polling place is actually a
accurately summed up.
Right.
So using A distributed ledger,
not to track the individual votes,
but to track the totals from each of the
polling places would be a way to allow
the public to understand,
okay,
the local polling place I went and voted
at is reporting a thousand votes,
500 for candidate x 500 for candidate.
Why?
That seems about right.
I don't know if my vote specifically
counted,
but I know that at least the polling
place I was at counted appropriately and
they didn't try to be pretend they were
100,000 votes.
Right?
So at the beginning of that process and
the tail end of that process using a
public distributed ledger to record that
makes a lot of sense,
but in the middle of the actual act of
walking into a booth and registering to
vote or um,
a lot of people want to do voting by
mobile device or by,
by computer.
I'm very worried about that.
The digitization of that.
Our computers fail us all the time and
malware and other,
other,
uh,
threats could really step in and make it
so that I think I'm voting for one
candidate,
but it gets recorded for another.
Right?
And we have to think in,
in the United States,
we care quite a bit about the
confidentiality of our vote.
Uh,
even to the point where I get no
receipt,
right?
I can't go to a bar and proved that I
voted for somebody and get a discount
for it.
Right?
That would be considered bribery,
so we can't simply come up with a system
that puts all the original votes into a
public ledger and provides proof that
somebody voted away a certain or that
becomes a corruptive process.
So I think we still need voter verified
paper balance as a path to auditing,
but with the registration,
the beginning and the summit at the end
conducted by a public ledger think we
would do a tremendous amount to
reestablish confidence in the voting
system.